[Music]
so we've had a lot of people make fun of
brendan chop
and the um
the time we've covered him
and i mean a lot of people
but
this one might be
my
favorite
one
okay so
what if i told you
that
dana white
made fun of brendan now let me give you
a quick back oh yeah
did you have this already
yeah what do you mean did i have this
oh cause i dropped it like
like a while back in show links and i
gave i i linked you to it oh i oh i i
also i also had it i just had it i was
gonna make sure where i i just found
this like as so you had it first but i
just want to make sure i was like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
somebody said this to me earlier but
this this is nuts okay quick background
i want to give a quick background so you
guys know what's going on
so um there was a there was a fighter
that didn't make weight at ufc was there
also a kid
well there was a fighter
that uh at the ufc that didn't make
weight whatever brendan schaub started a
conspiracy that the ufc told him not to
make weight because of abc for dump
which is stupid like why would you do
that right makes no sense
but
brendan brendan uh um dana white thought
that it was uh uh pat milchet miltich
that that's
milt titch that said it right
so everything he's saying now he's
talking about brendan but you also have
to wait to the end of it so
i'm gonna try this time to actually just
play it and not talk over it okay and
hamzad
came in on weight i mean when he landed
here he was lighter than he was his last
fight and he made weight
so
um i heard this thing today and again i
don't know how true it is or whatever
that
like pat milotic was saying
that this thing was
we told hamzat not to make weight
because we weren't selling tickets and
we weren't
the [ __ ] show was sold out going into
that day of the weigh-ins
i don't know if pat really said that but
if he did he has to be the dumbest
[ __ ] on the planet i mean you
know how [ __ ] stupid you have to be
to even think something like that let
alone say it publicly and act like
you're [ __ ] serious um
we're regulated by the athletic
commission
and
if you think that we told hamza chemiev
to not make weight then hamzad shows up
and the fans are all pissed off at him
and stuff and he's going to just i mean
and knowing if you know anything about
the sport this is a guy that was
actually in the sport
training and fighting and everything
else if pat really said that it's
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] we might have to send him out
to the [ __ ] uh clinic here the brain
clinic
get him [ __ ] checked out
all right buddy done with me i believe
that was brendan shaw who said that it
was what brendan chop who whom who made
up that conspiracy oh it wasn't pat
milotic i think so i apologize to pat
militant
that makes sense
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
bro
he dana white doesn't even [ __ ]
respect you man let's play the last part
again i believe that was brendan shaw
who said that it was what brandon chop
who whom who made up that conspiracy oh
it wasn't pat milotic i think so i i
apologize to pat militant
that makes sense
bye
can somebody turn that into a gift
please just dana white saying that makes
sense with him laughing and walking away
oh my god
[ __ ] what oh my god does anybody have
the clip of did brendan tweet that or or
did he
say that in a show
because i i obviously i i haven't found
it
yeah i need to know what brendan's got
to the [ __ ]
dana white is he ever not likeable at a
press conference
like i don't like any of these usually
like any of these like rich dudes i
don't know all these big companies
whatever but dana white's one that you'd
be like oh i'd hang out with dana white
like dana white is a guy that would be
like here come to vegas dude we're going
to smoke weed and shoot guns and [ __ ]
we're hanging
we got the bang energy guy here he
brought us whole foods family and
coaches they're filming some [ __ ]
yeah oh that i'm trying to see if
there's more
if there's any more info
on this michael bisping
militech's comments
look i i haven't i haven't screened it
but i think this is the clip of [ __ ]
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on yeah yeah hold on hold on hold
on yes send me that but just in case
here's a little background hold on hold
on hold on hold on here we go here we go
here's what pat initially said
how's everybody doing so this is the ufc
that is tonight it's pretty interesting
when you see a
guy that's wrestled his whole life a guy
from
told him i don't care about the pad
stuff for no reason he was told to
and by the way it turns out that pat did
say that so a member asked dana to
respond to this at the end
i don't know if pat really thinks
something like not make weight then and
fighting and everything else has to pass
damon got destroyed brendan posted this
i'm a little sick here you go here you
go
that makes sense
bye brendan schaub has responded to dana
brendan posted this to his instagram in
the cat
oh god here we go again i've been
nothing but cool than thought you
learned from the last time you mentioned
my name and got destroyed unfortunately
not surprised you're a bully always have
been you put a pair of designer jeans on
and some hip sneakers and think you're
cool is brendan talking to himself is
brendan talking to himself that brandon
just say always have been you put a pair
of designer jeans on some hip sneakers
and think you're cool brendan is
literally insulting him the way we
insult brendan you're still a dork with
a frat vocabulary
brendan chubb is saying that somebody
else is a dork and questioning their
vocabulary
calling me and numerous people dummy and
dumb ass is [ __ ] idiot because we
have questions about the chaos at ufc
279 also no one is talking about gate
tickets i was referring to pay-per-view
buys and how ufc 279 was trending which
you don't release to public to the
public brendan didn't write this but we
have
god here we go again i've been nothing
but cool and thought you'd learn from
the last time you mentioned my name and
got destroyed unfortunately not
surprised you're a bully always have
been you put on a pair of designer jeans
and some hip sneakers and you think
you're cool you're still a dork with a
frat bro bro hey hey brandon i'm not
going to defend anyway because i don't
[ __ ] care about that because didn't i
get the [ __ ] offend himself obviously
but brennan do not brennan you're a
[ __ ] dork who put on hips who put on
hip sneakers not only have hip sneakers
we had we shamed you off of taking your
sneakers off the table by the way we
know it was us don't think that we don't
know it was us and all and so so much so
that brian calling on meltdown on us
because of it because we don't [ __ ]
play sports stop pretending like you're
[ __ ] cool okay and honestly you
you're lucky you're friends with rogan
because you're gonna burn the you're
gonna you really want to keep burning
these this dana white bridge you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
vocabulary calling me in numerous people
dummy dumbass
idiot because hey you're you are a dummy
you're a dumbass and you're a [ __ ]
idiot but not even because of this
because you in general
brendan remember that video that cartoon
that we played yesterday marsh where it
was just showing brendan is actually
he's the bully brilliant brennan's the
bully in every situation and again he
does this all he does is lash out he
called dana white the bully when he's
the bully he said he's a dork and tips
jeans and sneakers when that's exactly
what his entire life is about your whole
identity is your shoes you [ __ ] [ __ ]
because they're the only thing they're
the only thing that has a lower iq than
you have questions about the chaos at
ufc 279 also no one is talking about
gate tickets i was referring to
pay-per-view buys and how ufc 279 was
trending which you don't release to the
public but we'll say it went great bros
sorry we don't just buy what you're
telling us after lying numerous times
but the sheet media you pick to attend
events don't have the balls to call you
out just in the recent press conference
you were caught lying about extra
compensation to the fighters do you want
to talk about lies brendan you want to
talk
like your best friend pete davidson
right like that
tom bob tom bite you didn't take the
fajita stroke
tomba you didn't take the fajitas joke
eh nick schwartzen's entire special
fajitas
disgraceful
you need a reality check you're
surrounded by yes men you're not special
you're not original you're a low budget
vince mcmahon every move you make is a
copycat bro he has a lot of money he's a
lot of things but low budget is not you
can't come on man low budget
that dude only thing you have in common
is your boat
i'm calling somebody a copycat is
[ __ ] caviar to my goddamn year it's
hilarious
it's hilarious he's so out of [ __ ]
touch bro
dress like apples need i remind you your
origin story is a failed cardio
kickboxing instructor who had two rich
friends in high school to fund this
business now
your origin story is you come from a
rich family where your dad was a
door-to-door consumer for computer
salesman and you were a mediocre fighter
at best and then when you left that you
were lucky to be friends with joe rogan
if not you wouldn't have got any
specials or a showtime career so much so
that you are the do you are the the fact
that you're saying all these things with
what with a straight face and pretending
brandon that you're not a laughing stock
of the comedy community blows my mind it
really does it blows my mind that the
[ __ ] guy who every comedian makes fun
of we have super cuts of comedians
making fun of him is trying to dunk on
somebody even if i hated dana white i
wouldn't side with you brandon because
you're a [ __ ] hypocritical [ __ ] i'll
go make a cool video with the nelk boys
to stay relevant or have your pr team
come up with a good press story to
distract the fans away from fighter pay
oh yeah no fighter pain oh you're right
why don't you make another cool video
with your fighter friends eating at a
food truck huh why don't you have
smothered onion rings again you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] oh um
[ __ ] is fire bee oh i'm eating a foot
long hot dog with angel
with with silva look randy couture me
are gonna are gonna share some spaghetti
the [ __ ] up brandon you [ __ ] how they
have to wear those awful under armour
rock shoes and won't see a dime dummy ps
quit stealing my shows on thick boy
network and recreating it on fight pass
okay also leave pat miller quit stealing
my shows on thick boy network
and recreating it on fight pass
alone brennan
also reposted this to his instagram
story it's a dm conversation with pat
milotic it says man that was fun last
night lol pat said dana is not gonna
like what i post today then it reads
they'd shop contact you he probably
hasn't seen that video the video of dana
going off it was deleted pat responded
tell shop to hit me up and we'll make
fun of dana
shop you can't even beat us
i mean i'm just want to be clear here
even with your thick boy network and
and the joe rogan resources and stuff
like that
we hurt we still hurt your feelings so
this tough guy attitude doesn't work
when you're a sensitive baby do you
understand that you made theo vaughn
hate doing podcasts and that guy could
do a podcast with a [ __ ] empty chair
and it's amazing do you understand that
that's how it's you and you know merch i
didn't think about this but when i was
looking at the clip channel somebody
commented um on the you know the theo
you know theovon leaving king in this
thing and they said the real reason that
he's leaving is because theo does not
agree
because theo's really good friends with
bobby he doesn't agree with what they
did to bobby when they put bobby through
but he won't say that but that's
probably the reason he's leaving
because remember we saw some of us as
the king of this thing after the bobby
lee thing we're going man you're both so
[ __ ] stupid and all that stuff
who are you guys siding with on this one
dana or brennan and pat post your
opinions in the comments and that's
gonna by the way did you see because he
knew this was gonna cover by the all the
news outlets
that he plugged his thick boy network in
it of course
he plugged his little thick boy network
with three c's
with three c's it's better it's one more
every day i mean i mean
it's such a hilaciously homosexual name
yeah
wow it's so [ __ ] thick boy is the gayest
thing